hey guys what's up this is andrew for
chances.com so welcome to the first
video of the year 2022 so first thing
guys happy new year to you all i wish
you have success and of course to make a
lot of money so
my good resolution for the year 2022 is
to pronounce the word analysis properly
analysis all right so let's do some
technical analysis today guys on amc
gamestop i want to go through everything
that happened actually last year uh it's
going to be a bit deeper the only
technical analysis i want to go through
the global market as well and try to
understand why economically speaking we
had this strong moves on the meme stocks
which we saw some big moves down in the
at the end of the year so let's try to
see if this is going to keep happening
and what we can expect for 2022 let's
get into it
[Music]
all right guys so i'm gonna be quick on
the ta let's start with amc so i'm on a
weekly time frame guys this time because
once again i wanna show you guys what
happened last year so i haven't posted
any video for quite some time guys
because you know i was in the process of
moving i was my family it was a bit
complicated but i was still active on
discord for those who are following me
there and so i'm going to show you guys
what happened the last day of the year
but the first thing that is important to
say guys is that we went up by
1200 percent in
the year 2021 so
the main reason behind that was the
unlimited flow of money guys that was
printed by the federal reserve so we're
gonna analyze that very very soon so
this is a great success even if we
finished the year a bit lower this is a
great success that needs to be told then
if i go on a daily timeframe guys in the
last video i posted i told you that you
know we broke out from the triangle here
i think i did my last video when we were
here and i was saying that 24 won't
probably hold that we will go to 21
before bouncing back all right this is
what happened here guys and right now
when you are on the daily time frame
guys we were having some very nice uh
things happening on uh thursday with a
strong move up plus 7 during the day we
were finally training above this 20-day
moving average that was here acting as
resistance as you guys can see we never
closed above we always played we tested
it many times but we never closed above
and then we closed above on thursday and
what happened on friday guys we went
lower so
you know we had the momentum with us
when i say we have the momentum with us
it means that whenever you cross the
price action is crossing the 20-day
moving average this is
creating some bullish momentum and
despite that bullish momentum which
still got rejected quite brutally and
finished the day at the low of the day
the volume was not impressive because
during the last week of the year
traders are not very active so
you know we are still above 27 which is
good all right 27 is the short-term
support but there are different
scenarios that might happen here
the first scenario is that unfortunately
we don't hold above 27. this scenario is
not nice guys all right because it would
mean that we have only completed an abc
here only three waves whenever you only
go up uh doing three waves not five this
means that the better than controller
right whenever the moves up are
developing five waves like i want to see
like one two three four five then it's
very good for the next move that usually
moves down and three waves and then you
go up again doing five waves here i
don't like what is happening and to be
honest guys i'm not sure what's gonna
happen next month but what i know
for sure guys is that we still have the
money in the economy so first let me
conclude on this technical analysis if
we break 27 it would be something like
this here we did one two three four five
so you see we developed in five waves on
the downside all right so it can be many
thing it can be a first impulse it can
be a c wave c wave and five waves
impulse and five waves but it means that
bears are in full control in here to
really stop the bars we need to develop
in five waves on the upside for now we
almost did it but we didn't manage to do
a fifth wave so if we don't do it then
unfortunately guys we might see a five
wave development again on the downside
with the next support i'm here to tell
you the truth guys all right i'm not
sure to tell you that everything will be
fine whatever happens all right
i i personally do believe that good
things are going to happen but i think
maybe a bit later it will depend what
happens around this 27 level but i give
you first the bearish case all right so
that you are prepared it's not my
preferred scenario it's one scenario all
right but at least we do it then we're
gonna do the bullish case so here if we
break 27 we can still bounce back all
right we have some support at 25 but
let's be honest it won't be looking good
because it would mean that we didn't
manage to do five waves on the upside
so
maybe we're gonna have a longer
correction here and then move up but it
would not be a good signal technically
speaking so if this happens 25 is the
next report but i think it's weak and
unfortunately we might develop lower and
the next support level if we start
developing five waves
doing five waves on the downside the
next support level is here guys around
15 we have the lower level of the gap
that is at 16 so 15 16 is the area of
support and when you go on the weekly
time frame you can see that we have here
the 200 week moving average coming here
so it's not a very strong uh support or
resistance but it's a level that is
important to keep in mind so this is for
the bearish test okay now the bullish
case guys
which was my preferred scenario on
thursday but after this strong moves
down i'm like 50 50. so let's see what
happens is that we complete uh so this
is not an abc the bullish case is that
we do one two three four five like this
guys so to do that first we will have a
good reaction on monday and we need to
break uh right now we broke the 20-day
moving average didn't give the good
results expected so i'm not sure exactly
what we need here but we would need
probably to go above this trend line so
above the 30 level you know something
like this and then we would have 32 as a
strong resistance that 200 day moving
average so you know we have a lot of
struggle uh in this area but that we can
go through so it will depend on what
happens on the rest of the market so if
this happens we will probably go to 37
but this and then do a small abc okay
this would be the
you know kind of normal scenario abc and
then starting here in fab we might see
some strong moves up okay so those are
my two scenarios of course i am uh in
i mean the bullish case is my preferred
scenario but let's be prepared for
anything that could happen and even if
you go to 16 my personal conviction is
that this move like i mean the meme
movement that started with amc and gme
will not be over why so first i'm going
to tell you my view on the spy very soon
because it's important because each time
amc moved strongly higher the spy was
moving lower but first yeah i think it's
time to talk about that let me let me
show you our first my view of the spy
very quickly i'm not going to spend too
much time here but it's important guys
that you are aware of that so basically
222 will be very challenging because as
you guys probably heard the federal
reserve will increase the rates alright
the short-term rates from
0.25 percent 25 beeps to 75 or maybe one
percent at the end of the year so
whenever the rates are going higher it
makes things more difficult there is
less free money you need to pay to
borrow money so you know it just slows
down a bit the mechanisms in the economy
so it's not good for the economy let's
be honest but we need to at some point
put the rates higher otherwise whenever
the inflation is going too high it's not
sustainable so we have inflation coming
so the rates need to go up this is the
problem that the federal reserve is
facing
and my view on the spy is that we were
developing here
doing a one two three four five all
right this is the end of the comet
crisis the low march 20 one two three we
are completed the third wave so a force
wave is coming guys fourth wave that
will be quite i think uh long uh in time
like the second wave lasts
two months roughly so we can expect a
force wave to last two three months
maybe even a bit longer and we arrive i
think when i do my countings and
everything we arrive at the top of the
third wave very very soon i think we
might have one or two more moves up so
basically it would start in one week or
in five weeks something like this
between 480 and 490. so the correction
and i'm talking about the correction and
the spy and once again and this
correction would last probably two three
months and then we would strongly bounce
back so let me a bit develop what i mean
here first uh as you guys saw i posted
that on twitter you can check it trading
sensors uh this is my twitter account
i'm not very active there but i posted
this information that that i think is
interesting and you can see basically
here you you've probably seen that
already but let me show you again
whenever amc moves strongly higher so
the green arrows here uh the spy was
starting with a move down and we can see
that the correlation which is the blue
curve here each time mc moves strongly
higher the correlation was going down
and was most of the time negative
especially here in jan 21 when we had
the first real squeeze
may june 22 21 as well but even before
it happened five times right and the
reason behind that guys is that hedge
funds are actually having a lot of long
positions on the global market and
whatever the global market is going down
brutally suddenly
they're facing margin calls so whenever
they face margin calls they need to
close some of the positions that consume
the more margin and what is consuming
the more margin on the balance sheet
guys it's amc why because whenever the
more risk you have the more conception
of the higher the margin requirements
are because you need to you know show
some money in case you make some losses
and there is no position that consumes
more than a short position on amc
because the loss is unlimited and we saw
what happened last year so of course
whenever you bear a short position on
amc you need to show a lot of money so
whenever the market is crashing you need
to once again close the positions that
consume the more margin and
amc gme are part of those positions so
they would rather go to those positions
to be able to keep the long positions
this is how hedge funds are working so
let me sum up a bit what i've just said
i expect the spy like i showed you guys
to take a downturn because the rates are
going higher and once again guys i
showed you that on discord so here i
have a lot of information but in 2016 uh
we had the same phenomenon and you can
go and check it out in 2016 january uh
not a few months after they announced
that they were doing the tapering and
the rates were going higher in 2016 five
years ago the market took one or two
months to crash right so now it's been
one or two months we are aware that the
rates are gonna go higher so we can
expect the market to correct sooner and
this is what i
get as well when i do my elliot wave
counties as you can see here one two
three four five we are developing in the
fifth wave since october 21 and one two
three four five we are in the fifth of
the fifth we are yeah in the fifth of
the fifth of the third something like
this so it's not very precise but it
gives me good information so i think
that the google market will dive
this can give us some nice reactions uh
on amc but it's going to be complicated
for amc to really squeeze and you know
hold for long whenever the market is
crashing so we would need probably to
wait for the rebound the fifth wave of
the s p 500 of the global market that
might happen i don't know maybe in march
maybe in april i think we need for that
to wait for this event to happen so this
bull market to start again before seeing
the the meme stocks coming higher again
so this is what i wanted to show you
guys and why do i believe so basically
what happened in 2021 is that once again
there is there was this unlimited flow
of money and right now there is the
tapering what is the tattering yes it's
just that the money that has been
printed is not going to be you know the
quantitative easing which is basically
some asset repurchasing program which
means the federal reserve is buying a
lot of assets to banks to some big
companies even now by using bonds and to
make the money the flow of the money
easier quantitative easing and right now
they're not gonna destroy this money let
me show you something right if you just
stop fed
saint luis
right
balance sheets
okay so this is the information you want
to have a look at you take the first
link guys and this is the balance sheet
of the fed okay
so what you can see is that they have
they started to print money in 2008 okay
they were at 1 000
billion us dollars and they printed you
know
non-stop for the past 10 years and then
the kobe crisis happened and they
printed
lemons amount of money from four
thousand billion to seven thousand
billion in a matter of a few months and
what happened since then the whole year
they kept printing we are right now at
nine thousand billion uh
so it's basically roughly 50 of the usd
gdp which is 20 000
billion dollars if i'm correct and so
what is gonna happen right now we're
gonna have some tapering which means
they're gonna print less okay but
they're not gonna destroy the money as
you can see here there was a bit of uh
they were destroying the money they
created all right they did it for one
year because all the economic indicators
were very good right now it's not i mean
it is the case but we still have omicron
that is around us the kobe is still here
they're not in the same process as you
guys can see here they are not
destroying the money yet they're keep
printing but they're printing less and
they intend to stop printing in march so
we still have three months of a lot of
money in the market and then guys what
is gonna happen they're not gonna
destroy this money look it's gonna be
here for at least two three years all
right and if the money is here so
i mean
assets are still gonna stay at high
levels and we're gonna see some
rotations from different stocks from
different sectors so this is the reason
why i believe the bubble is coming the
huge bubble i'm talking about that guys
for more than one year you can check my
video that i posted eight months ago on
nasdaq and s p 500 on my on my channel
when i was telling you guys that the snp
will will trade at 7 000 in right now
maybe one year and since then we only
went uh higher and higher and i believe
we will keep going higher but we have a
correction that is coming a healthy
correction maybe 10 15
we might go to the 420 level you know
something like this this would make
sense so it would be a correction of 15
10 15 nothing bigger than that amc is
already quite low all right so maybe it
won't go that lower but let's be honest
if we have a correction in the global
market uh this is basically the view
that i was giving you either we go
higher and then we come back you know
we're gonna do something like this and
the real squeeze
might i know guys i'm always delaying
that but you know this is
i can't fight what is really happening
and this is my view i give you the best
analysis
that i can and this is what i think
might happen now either we go lower than
higher or higher and lower but we won't
squeeze right now because i think the
correction is coming but once again i
believe that the movement uh that is on
amc and can stop is so strong that
whenever this rotation will occur uh
people are gonna go to stocks like amc
that would actually have a lot of room
on the upside so this is my view guys
and let's do quickly gme so basically
what has been said for amc which is the
negative correlation with the global
market is true the margin calls will
happen the same way whenever we we're
gonna see some strong moves down on the
s p 500 we probably gonna see
some strong moves up on gme as well
uh one thing i haven't showed you guys
yet uh is the synthetic short all right
so very interesting so bam you guys know
the spreadsheet uh right now we are
having 30 percent of total shots all
right 12
on the synthetic short interest and 6
and 18.8 as of the 15th of december on
the uh regular short interest so total
30 percent 3.3 dtc guys so that's a lot
but 3.3 is what we have always had but
we were at 2.5 a few weeks ago so it
means that there was some a big increase
in the synthetic short on amc which
means people bought a lot of options
that are closer to the money so what i'm
very interested in and this is a good
way to assess if the movement is still
on and for now it is is by checking the
option market and see how active it is
and right now as you guys can see the
biggest expiry is jan 22. we have 50
million equivalent shares of open
interest here all right most of it comes
from as you guys know
the 145 strike
so
i'm very curious to see if this is going
to get rolled for now we have 50 million
here you can see then we have 7 million
12 million
4 million and only 8 million on gen 23
so let's see how many of those options
are going to get rolled because let's be
honest we won't probably be trading at
145 in gen 22 because of like the
current situation so let's see if this
options are rolled or not and if people
maybe go to lower strikes which i think
is better in terms of probability of
making money but you know it's still a
good indicator to see how much people
believe in the squeeze by buying this a
very high strike so i'm going to keep
monitoring that but for now the data is
as usual guys very hot and anything can
happen at any time as long as we start
to move higher and this is the issue
we're having right now is that we are
stuck down and that bears eye are very
active okay let me go back to gme guys
so jimmy the situation guys is that
let's go on a weekly time frame
so you guys know that we broke out on
the downside from this triangle you know
i was very you know sad to see that uh
here you know things were looking so
great but you know we went the other way
around
which is uh life it happens it's like
that so let's see what can happen from
here we are neutral between 130 and 160
if we managed to break
to break out above 160 we would probably
go test this old support that is now
resistance so something like this may
happen and let's see what can happen
here so this is the bullish case the
bearish case is that we go below 130
it's possible then we'll probably find
support at 116 which is the next support
i don't think we would really go lower
than that let's say the lowest level we
could go
i think if amc goes to 14 jimmy will
probably go to
i don't have any strong support here
guys
i don't know okay i don't have any
strong support to me the strong support
i have is 116 so i don't think we might
go really lower than that
in terms of percentage we're talking
about 20
let's see
for now we are neutral between 100 and
360.
the two scenarios are like that and what
has been said for amc is true for gme
guys so
let's see i think we need a bit more
time for the real moves up to happen we
are trending below the 100 day moving
average which is not bullish guys let's
be honest uh so we need to take it back
but after this strong moves down like we
had here the market needs time yes like
i've been saying uh before so
i i don't think we might go right away
like this on the upside we would take
some time i don't know
either we go lower first then higher or
we go higher first and then lower all
right so it's one of the two and then
here so maybe you know in march maybe in
june
we would see those strong moves up
happening once again why yes because
technical analysis as you can see is
helpful but sometimes you know it
doesn't tell you exactly what will
happen but the reasoning that uh you
know um i personally have been using it
when i was uh you know a professional
trader for the past six years six seven
years is that you analyze the flows of
the money all right and try to
understand what investors would do with
this money and the analysis i did with
the balance sheet of the fed 9 000
billion us dollars of fake money that is
injected in the system and that's you
know rotates this money needs to find a
home that will rotate amongst different
sectors and uh you know at some point
it's going to get back to amc ngme so we
just need to wait for this moment to
happen right now the technicals are
telling us that it might take some time
but the money is here and it's huge so
this is why i believe a bubble is coming
and it's going to be maybe apple maybe
amazon
microsoft google all the stocks and at
some points it's going to be amc gme
squeeze bam so this is what is i think
ahead of us lasting
gme synthetic short bam
it's a bit long video i know guys
it's big
seven yet seven guys so you see
i mean it can happen anytime all right
it can happen anytime whenever we have
everything that is related that is i
mean coming together combined and goes
in the same direction we're gonna see
man like look at that
look at this strong like very big open
interest on the 300 there is it's
everywhere right i haven't checked gme
for like a couple of uh days or weeks
and i haven't seen it it has grown like
that okay even on the downside
it's really big and uh this shows us
guys that whenever you know things will
be all together pointing in the same
direction the squeeze will happen that's
it end of the question
so
guys that's it for today once again i
wish you a very happy new year i will
keep doing these videos guys until this
quiz happens right now i'm working a lot
on the training a full course about
technical analysis about everything that
i've been using at work when i was a
trader it's gonna be some pdf it's gonna
be some videos i'm gonna send you guys
everything once it is ready it is not
yet so i'm working a lot on that
i'm still very active on discord uh if
you guys want to see come in the free
area you know you can chat you can ask
me questions i will answer maybe not
right away because you know i need to
take care of all the members as well but
i'm gonna be here
and i'm gonna start very soon guys to do
some live trading on discord of course
but on youtube as well so you know even
if you're not on discord you can you're
gonna be able to see that i'm gonna
apply the methods that i'm talking about
right now in my course and i'm gonna
keep of course updating you guys the
name see jamie every weekend so that's
it for today once again guys i wish you
a very happy new year and stay close to
shore as you guys